let's talk about what's happening with
this people's convoy
we have this story from the daily mail
the people's convoy reaches illinois as
it makes its way to washington dc for
trucker anti-mandate protest capital is
on high alert ahead of state of the
union address i will also add over at
timcast.com we have a reporter elad
who's currently tracking with the convoy
right now he's he's going alongside and
interviewing them those videos are up be
a member if you want but they're free we
get that news reporting to you guys but
this is interesting because this is not
the freedom convoy this is the people's
convoy it's different yeah yeah so the
freedom convoy i don't yeah i don't know
if the freedom convoy for the us like
didn't make it or or what's going on
with it i i don't i don't i thought it
was just one whole time i was surprised
it was like 12. actually i just know
there's a convoy and it's got about 250
people and it's going to be arriving in
dc on the 5th
and they're like i've mentioned maybe
it's just for the state of the union but
they have put up all the barricades
around the white white house sorry the
capitol
two different white buildings
they put up all the barricades they're
pretty worried about this do you guys
think it's going to
get like trudeau level where it's just
going to be honking in the capital no
no what do you think is going to happen
the the dc police
are very very good at dealing with
protests
and i imagine for one the truckers
probably i think it's a there's a good
chance they won't even be able to make
it into the city um
as they start arriving there's gonna be
cops at key entry points and they're
gonna you know fan the trucks in the
other direction so they i don't i don't
think the trucks will get into the heart
of dc like like what happened with with
ottawa boy did they really screw that up
the simple logistics could have
prevented the protesters from succeeding
but man canada trudeau
and the provincial government didn't
seem to know how to handle that but i
think the us is going to be able to more
importantly however i think the bigger
risk is
they'll let them come in
and then you'll get some narrative about
insurrection again yeah yeah yeah
they'll they'll manipulate it they'll
use it and they'll say oh let them come
and there's already been reports people
are saying that there have been feds who
are trying to infiltrate or incite
people and they're like no no no so i'm
hearing that
many of the people are saying they don't
want to go to the core of dc for that
reason they want to stay slightly
outside so they can make their point you
know be like protest and you know
obstruct enough without actually
getting anywhere near close to these
buildings well isn't it interesting that
this had the effect of making people
feel
building parking garage and let the
trucks go in there and they're like they
they had an insurrection in the parking
garage they weren't supposed to be in
there he's got an open invite ray wants
to come on the show and uh
talk about stuff
maybe i don't know about that fbi no fbi
what's up maybe i think we have to i
think he had to have to do a sit-down
interview answering a ton of questions
before we would just have you know can
you just buy did you just buy a lie
detector yes
did we just buy one for i would like
donuts or something with the fridge you
needed a live stream oh yeah somebody
somebody we i bought a bunch of these
donuts and they come with you have to
like build them yourself yeah is that
you no did someone eat just the doughnut
ian's got fries they just ate the frost
face worse that was amazing someone
someone stole blasphemy seven icings
from our doughnuts we have other sugars
in the house why would they be i want
people but they didn't eat the donut
so somebody like took the icing and just
drank it i would be so good i think it
might have been joe biden that's
probably who's the sugar joe biden's
sneaking in at three in the morning and
he's like
come on
but he's whispering to himself come on
man as he's open up the dump come on
he's hunter so anyway yes oh man the
plan is we're everyone's denying it so
we got a lie detector we i think we're
ordering one or something like like a
fake you know thrift store like detector
or something like that a used polygraph
can you get like a top top cia quality
lie detector can you just just just just
it's all bsn don't worry yeah they don't
really work because it's if you think
you're lying it'll go if you're if you
have agitation but if you're lying in
your calm it won't know that's that's
why they don't use the record right
it's looking to see if you're stressed
by the question yeah so if you're
nervous the whole time it's fine but if
they see stress when you answer a
question they're going to think by the
way that's how the neural net and
metaverse is going to be tracking you if
they sense your emotions oh dude they
can read everything you gotta have to
have just a solidly clear mind when
you're in there i've already joined the
um what are we calling it are we calling
it the continuum or the singularity the
singularity oh gosh why the singularity
don't like that so i got a whoopee the
boss
yeah luke convinced me he said one of us
when i was like no luke stop and then he
pinned me down and he put the whoop on
my wrist
it tracks your health and it shows you
like your strain and your recovery it
shows you your heart rate your skin
temperature your you know
resting heart rate my resting heart rate
48. beautiful it's pretty good yeah
actually so uh i went to the doctor for
a physical because i was feeling sick
turns out i was dehydrated and they
hooked me up to the heart rate thing and
i looked at it and it was in the low 50s
and then it dropped down to like 45 and
it started going where where where like
low heart rate warring yeah and i was
just like what do i do like yeah i'm
fine and the nurse came in and she was
like are you very active and i was like
yeah and she's like okay and then she's
like ignored it yeah when i worked in
the cardiology unit we had a biker guy
who was ended up in one of the icu units
i'm assuming he got hit by a car or
something and his alarm was constantly
buzzing we had to set it to a lower rate
because he was like hanging out in the
40s 38 39 they thought he had a heart
block and i was like no i was just
really freaking fit it turns out wow
yeah yeah my goal is to get my resting
heart rate to one not doesn't work just
for a moment no i don't think so
the lowest i've ever seen it was uh for
me was 42. that's really low yep and you
know uh
like i exercise a lot but anyway the
whoop is it you know somebody said
because luke was wearing one on the show
and somebody said that it like sends all
your data to the corporations or
whatever it's like a bunch of lasers and
it's tracking everything and i'm like i
don't know it's telling me you know i
have it all on youtube luke you know you
know what the interesting thing is oh
when i wake up it tells me like here's
your recovery from your sleep and it's
always telling me that i need to sleep
for like 12 hours but i sleep for like
six and i'm like i can't sleep anymore
i'm working you know but it shows my my
recovery rate the funny thing is i don't
need it to tell me if i feel good when i
wake up because i feel good or i feel
bad that's weird that it's telling you
you feel good no it's just things it has
like 78 recovery or something it's a
green and it's like good job but when i
wake up i'm like i feel great because
technically it's proprietary and if a
crazy person gets the corporation they
could be like yeah let's tell him he
feels like trash let's tell him it's
resting heart rate's way lower than it
is like screw it no but uh when i was
dehydrated i had two nights where my
recovery was extremely low and the issue
was i was drinking regular water
not getting electrolytes so i wasn't
retaining and that was the problem
interesting so i i thought like i drank
a bunch of water and then i was told by
the doctor drink gatorade and so i drank
a bunch of gatorade and then all of a
sudden i was like oh man your heart
needs electrolytes i did not realize
because i'm always drinking you know
water or uh like like lemon juice and
water and stuff like that so
electrolytes it was making that black
water is really good we got this new
mineral black water it's a little sweet
and it's dark dark dark brown with
minerals 72 different added minerals
pretty cool it looks cool it's a gimmick
yeah i wonder if it is yeah you know
what you guys have two downstairs you
have air and a tank air and a canyon
you know what it's not the same thing
so you know this is you know i'm a smart
ass right so we were at we were at
youtube
we were at dick's sporting goods and uh
we were getting a new treadmill and
we're getting a new workout thing
because we like we genuinely here want
everyone to work out and i even said
like i'll get like a trainer to get
everybody to exercise because we want
people to eat right and be better and be
strong and um the guy they have these
oxygen canisters
at the uh
at the counter when we're checking out
and i said you know inhaling pure oxygen
is bad for you it's 95
and the guy goes no it's just air and i
was like
nope actually it's not it's oxygen and
it goes and what do you breathe and i
was like we breathe air
which is a combination of mostly
nitrogen carbon dioxide oxygen trace
gases like methane and then he was like
oh and i'm like people really think that
we breathe oxygen that's like all air is
78 nitrogen yeah i'm pretty sure it
wouldn't wouldn't like the atmosphere
ignite if it was if it was like
above like certain percentage of oxygen
or something like that oh interesting
yeah that's probably why it burned off
that's probably what happened i don't
know i'm not going to pretend to know
all about that all i know is that i
learned when i was like fifth grade
that's mostly nitrogen or whatever yeah
it just breathes a lot of nitrogen
nitrogen's a fascinating chemical
is it so it's air it's it's i'm sorry
it's gas it's not air when you say
what's in there it's gas it's fluid it's
not necessarily air
oh hey the air i guess all right so the
air come on yeah so yeah let's go with
it
they officially started the state of the
union stream we started early
no no no no no i can't believe brian's
trying to compete the stream has begun
but right now it's just a picture of joe
biden he needs like a band to play it
like why do you think or something why
do you think they disabled the comments
like i thought there was like a first
amendment here in the united states 81
million why do you think they hit the
dislike count that's crazy do you hey
install the install the the dislike
button uh app
on chrome let's check that right now
it doesn't have it on my laptop it
doesn't actually show you the real
dislike it guesses
based on what did you get it guess it's
based on uh
you can read you can read they say the
first wave was based on the data they
already had on dislikes and the next is
based on metrics that correlate with
dislikes or something i feel like we
could test this theory by looking in the
back end and then getting someone else
to use it on our video you know
i could see you could track the amount
of total clicks then the amount of total
likes and then subtract it and get the
amount of total dislikes i will say it's
like button anymore i've noticed that
since they've gotten rid of the dislike
button i get way less dislikes yeah i
was going to say people don't feel as
driven to do so because it's not going
to be a bad look for you in the
beginning
it was a five star remember when they
used to rate five stars one through five
stars i would give someone five stars or
i wouldn't vote i hated trashing people
like uber drivers yeah you gotta give
him five stars here that's right yeah or
just don't worry otherwise they get
fired they know unless they're speeding
and then let everyone know that that's
safe
um so so they disabled the comments and
i just want to say so we have right here
the president's state of the union
address from the white house official
youtube which of course is public domain
of course and uh chet is disabled
i just uh i would love to see that
nightmare of a hellscape
if they allowed it and they should and i
actually think um i think
they should be obligated to have that
because
it's what's interesting is it says
they've disabled it that means the
government has barred the public from
something that should be there like
didn't they try to sue donald trump for
blocking people on twitter yes yeah now
the argument they could say is
by having no chat for anyone it's not
very equal you know it but i would argue
this
they've disabled chat for the public and
chat is a basic core function of a live
stream therefore my argument is the
government is suppressing the right of
the people to speak at a public event
and associate especially when the
internet has become the new public
sphere you look at with lockdown like
you forced us in our homes and now we're
all online and now we've got the
metaverse and now this is the new public
sphere where we all talk and
you know deal with our issues and yeah
so if the president was doing it in the
public square and and a politician was
speaking the public square and they said
you can come and watch this but don't
you dare speak to your neighbor well let
me let me ask i'm gonna i'll ask the
audience uh for those that are listening
do you think that we should uh inquire i
say inquire because uh do you think we
should inquire about filing a lawsuit
over the disabling of chats for public
broadcasts hit one if you think no no
hit 20. because 20 means you wrote a 20
you're correct
yeah if you think we should inquire
about suing to to enable make sure that
core chat functions that are a basic
part
so let me explain i say inquire because
i don't know the law we'll talk to a
lawyer and see what they say but here's
my argument
when you start a live stream and we do
every day monday through friday not
every single day but we have to actually
choose to not have a chat
we click
disabled actually they may have changed
that
no i think it's still you can enable and
disable chat but i think it's
they might have changed it to by default
be disabled in which case it's replay is
disabled by default but i think chat is
automatic well so there's the question
if chat is everyone's saying 20.
if if chat is a
it says chet is disabled that says to me
that they have chosen to remove it
i think then the government should not
have access to remove something it's a
private company youtube uh donald trump
got sued and lost over blocking people
yeah i don't think biden should be able
to get rid of the streams and i believe
that you know you know why they disabled
it because it would be people saying we
hate you you're awful we hate you it
would be funny as it would be hysterical
yeah it would but instead because
the public is not allowed to comment on
this and make fun of biden we're gonna
have to provide that service for you
guys i'm sorry thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there